the victims range in age from 5 to 72 so
far we know the names of three of the 26
people killed Emily Ward was seven years
old
Joanne ward was a mother of four Annabel
Pomeroy who was 14 is the pastor's
daughter Omar Villafranca is also in
Sutherland Springs here on mark good
morning good morning Sutherland Springs
Georgia sheriff's a small and tight-knit
only a few hundred people live here
everyone knows everyone and it's like
you said there's a church over there
there's the post office where yesterday
dozens of people gathered here to offer
up their prayers but also wonder why
hours after gunfire claimed the lives of
more than two dozen members of this
community there were candles and tears
Joyce Emily lives in nearby Lavernia any
type of act that they were doing in the
church there was somebody lost in almost
every aspect I think among the dead 14
year old Annabel Pomeroy pastor Frank
Pomeroy's daughter Annabel has been
wanting to ride with me and go with me
here and there and his sermon two
weekends ago the pastor talked about how
he rode his Harley to church Annabel
down like it was a beautiful ride yes it
was a little chilly but watching the Sun
come up over the the Sun was just coming
up as we were riding down 467 she was
that good cuddled behind me and when I
pointed at the temperature gauge I felt
her snuggling even tighter pastor Frank
and his wife sherry were both out of
state when the shooting happened also
among the victims seven-year-old Emily
and her mother Joanne ward a friend
confirmed her passing on Facebook
writing is it possible to physically
feel your heartbreak we're we're as
small as we call a small little redneck
town in the country why this church why
people that I grew up with you know why
why then
Texas governor Greg Abbott attended last
night's vigil earlier have some advice
for grieving Texans as governor I asked
for every mom and dad at home tonight so
you put your arm around your kid and
give your kid a big hug and let them
know how much you love them this
shooting may have been captured on
camera the church routinely records
their Sunday services and then post them
on YouTube Jeff people in this community
are now wrestling with the idea that a
large percentage of the residents here
were killed thank you very much as we
head back to New York now it's a Gail
Gail it is uh it's almost impossible for
everyone here to wrap their wrap their
minds around exactly what what happened
yesterday it's impossible for anybody
anywhere Jeff thank you very much to
wrap your brains around what's happening
we always keep asking why why why no
matter what the answer is it's never
gonna be satisfying never gonna be fun
it's another one of those stories here
we go again
I've snuffed out that's right the
daughter that can never speak to you in
a small town like the five-year-old I
love the question is it possible to
physically feel your heartbreak the
answer is yeah look at that story